Donald Trump yesterday had one of the
most concerning and outrageous days on
Twitter maybe of his entire presidency
and in the past when we've talked about
Trump's crazy Twitter days it's often
the number of times that he's tweeting
sometimes a hundred times dozens and
dozens of tweets and retweets but
yesterday was not crazy in terms of the
number of tweets but it was crazy
because of the content of the tweets
including very strange tweets about Iran
as well as retweeting an image of Nancy
Pelosi in Muslim dress in front of an
Iranian flag and the world continues to
laugh at us day in and day out because
this madman is our president and the
proportions of this have expanded beyond
even absurdity into something
reminiscent of an unbelievable alternate
universe let's take a look at the
completely erratic bipolar nature of
these tweets I'm using bipolar not in
the medical sense simply relating to
extremes of different kinds Donald Trump
starting with to the leaders of Iran do
not kill your protesters thousands have
already been killed or imprisoned by you
and the world is watching more
importantly the USA is watching turn
your internet back on and let reporters
roam free stop the killing of your great
Iranian people generally speaking a good
sentiment but couched with a sort of
strange threat in it then going into
mini Mike Bloomberg is spending a lot of
money on false advertising I was the
person who saved pre-existing conditions
in your health care you have it now
seemingly taking credit for Obamacare
which of course he is criticized and has
nothing to do with while at the same
time winning the fight to rid you of the
expensive unfair and very unpopular
individual mandate which is the only
thing holding Obamacare together going
on to say and if Republicans win in
court and take back the House of
Representatives your hell health care
that I have now brought to the best
place in many years will become the best
ever by far I will always protect your
pre-existing conditions and the
Democrats will not of course a complete
and total lie
then Donald Trump retweeting some anti
Nancy Pelosi stuff then retweeting a
picture of Chuck Schumer wearing a
turban
and Nancy Pelosi wearing Muslim dress of
course a doctored image not a real one I
assume I don't have to tell most people
in the audience that and then after all
this it really got crazy with a multi
tweet screed where Trump says Bernie
Sanders volunteers misspelling Bernie's
name are trashing Elizabeth pocahontas
warren misspelling pocahontas everybody
knows her campaign is dead and want her
potential voters many mike b is also
trying but getting tiny crowds which are
all leaving fast elizabeth is very angry
at Bernie do I see a feud brewing going
on to say the Democrats and the fake
news are trying to make terrorists
soleimani into a wonderful guy
completely untrue only because I did
what should have been done for 20 years
anything I do whether it's the economy
military or anything else will be
scorned by the RAF achill left
do-nothing Democrats then he praised
Iranian protesters and went into calling
for impeachment to simply end or I guess
he means be canceled saying why should I
have the stigma of impeachment attached
to my name when I did nothing wrong
read the transcripts he's not released
them a totally partisan hoax never
happened before House Republicans voted
195 to 0 with three Dems voting with the
Republicans very unfair to tens of
millions of voters almost as unfair is
the senators representing just 7% of the
population getting to acquit Donald
Trump as I spoke about before Trump
continuing many believe that by the
Senate giving credence to a trial based
on no evidence no crime read the
transcripts no pressure impeachment hoax
rather than an outright dismissal it
gives the partisan Democrat witch-hunt
credibility that it otherwise does not
have I agree seemingly suggesting that
it should all just be canceled and going
on and on and on including Donald Trump
appearing to tweet a picture of a dead
body during this wild uncontrolled
string of images and posts a bloody male
figure draped over a barbed wire fence
being tweeted by Donald Trump my hope is
that after we remove Donald Trump in
November of course still is the top
priority that these tweets do become
part of the historical record so that we
all remember the true nature of living
through this era where you have this
additional constant whacked-out
narrative happening on Twitter by Donald
Trump we've learned money cannot buy you
class the Donald Trump family is Exhibit
A in that realization but beyond that we
need this as part of the historical
record because we need to never forget
that Republican senators effectively
stood by and allowed this to continue 20
of them could end this insanity with a
single vote and they're not going to do
it and we can't allow history to be
written in a way where that is anything
short but a completely disgusting and
irresponsible action by Republicans in
the House and Senate I have something
that I think you're going to enjoy today
there's a young woman named Caitlin
Bennet
who I had never heard of before
yesterday before seeing the videos I'm
gonna play for you today but apparently
she's known as gun girl in some circles
she's a pro-gun anti-abortion anti trans
seemingly religious conservative she
strikes me as a religious conservative
although although maybe that's not the
case wikipedia says that Bennett
received media attention in 2018 because
she opened carried an ar-10 rifle at
Kent State University imagine being
known for holding a gun holding a gun is
what she's known for
I believe she's 23 24 years old she goes
to college campuses and she does these
horribly bad faith dishonest gotcha type
interviews where she wants to show how
crazy things are on liberal college
campuses and she asks students what do
you think about abortion or what do you
think about guns or trans people it's
done totally out of context and very bad
faith and she did this the other day and
a young man who has upper management
written all over him I think you will
agree after watching this segment
stopped her short when she started
asking Oh what about tampons in men's
rooms or what about this or that and the
kid very clearly says who cares
no one's committing a crime
I'm living my life I believe in
individual liberty who cares about this
stuff check this out how do you think
about putting urinals and women's
restrooms for women who have penises and
they just want to stand and peek I think
people just making too big of fun
naughty words okay so we should or
shouldn't I mean I'll really care okay
what about tampons and pads and men's
restroom for men who have periods if
you're really getting that worked up
about it why doesn't matter like I don't
care just sitting there I'm not gonna
take it okay we should provide men with
tampons I mean if a dude wants a tampon
for some reason he can have a tampon
that's not my business what would he use
it for I don't know that's his problem
well we use a pad for his problem do you
think they should seek medical advice if
they're having bleeding I mean if they
want to I don't really care why should I
care I care about people they're
bleeding out of their penis I would want
to I care about people's personal rights
they can do whatever they want some none
of my business
beautifully done absolutely beautifully
done this is like a fake reactionary
libertarian this woman Caitlyn Bennett
meeting an actual libertarian and I mean
libertarian in the authoritarian versus
libertarian sense not like a capital L
libertarian who says there's no crime
being committed there's no violence to
anyone there's no interference with my
life what do I care about where a tampon
is found she has nowhere to go with it
because she can't get an emotional
response from the student so she has to
become more unhinged and start saying
things like what about a bleeding penis
then here's another one that went
horribly wrong and and she actually is
so unbearable that I almost started
feeling bad for how dumb she looked here
but then I didn't take a look at this
there's there's there's more than people
think what men having periods mm-hmm
yeah my god did you tell them to seek
clinical help if men are having periods
trans men have berries
okay okay explain nothing to me yeah so
us people who have transitioned from
female to male you know obviously you
know they might still have periods and
you know if they identify as male you
know they have the right to go into the
men's room but if they're still having
periods they have the right to have you
know the products they need this is of
course how these reactionary social
conservative movements work they work by
strategically narrowly framing questions
when it makes sense and then when it's
more convenient you broaden it where the
questions and the topic are way too
broad to actually have any meaning and
if conservative I'm sorry conspiracy
theorists actually do the same thing
there's a strategy in pushing conspiracy
theories where you will sometimes say
let's zoom way out in order to further
your conspiracy theory but when taking a
broad view actually hurts your
conspiracy theory you zoom way in in to
narrowly a calculated details and it's a
very similar strategy here first they go
very broad something like the identity
politics left thinks men can have
periods okay well it's not hard to
understand if you're born biologically
female you transition to male unless you
have certain procedures you've got a
uterus you have the reproductive system
doesn't go away so someone who
identifies as male in society and uses
the men's room might still have a period
menstruation may still be part of their
biological reality so then they go
abroad and they write that the left
thinks men has pure you have periods or
something like that and then when you
point out how absurd the framing is they
will narrow it to are you telling me you
don't care about someone whose penis is
bleeding
this isn't about a man whose penis is
bleeding this is about individual
liberty it's about rights it's about
nobody's breaking any laws and the most
important takeaway here because it's an
election year is that these people vote
and many people agree with the framing
of Kate Caitlyn Caitlyn Bennett she gets
to vote the people who find her
intelligent and who find her videos
prescient
about the future
of America they vote and none of this
means anything if we can't start fixing
this problem from the bottom up and that
means we all have to vote in November of
2020 I want to hear from you what do you
think about these videos we'll take a
quick break and be back right after this
we really need a president who is not
the laughingstock of the world then once
again world leaders have been caught on
video laughing at Donald Trump this time
it's Russian President Vladimir Putin
and Syrian dictator Bashar al-assad
remember that it was Donald Trump who
said we need a non laughingstock
president he tweeted back in 2014 when
Barack Obama was president we need a
president who isn't the laughingstock to
the entire world
we need a truly great leader a genius at
strategy and winning respect he claimed
he would be that president here's video
of Putin and Assad laughing at Trump now
of course they're not speaking in
English it's Russian with Putin using
the aid of a translator so I'll
summarize what was said per Axios the
video shows the leaders talking to each
other while visiting the Orthodox Church
of the Virgin Mary in Damascus Assad
tells Putin about the Apostle Paul who
became a Christian at the gate of
Damascus and he jokingly says if Trump
arrives along this road everything will
be normal with him to Putin then laughs
and tells Assad it will be repaired
invite him he will come and Assad
answers he's ready to invite Trump to
which Putin responds smiling I will tell
him and they all laugh and what you have
to understand is the literal translation
doesn't really do it justice let's look
at the video where they are just
laughing and having a grand old time
laughing at Trump then I'll explain the
sort of gist of this
this is happening all the time world
leaders laughing at Trump so the literal
translation doesn't make the joke
totally obvious but it would sort of be
like saying you know you should invite
Trump to visit the road to Damascus if
walking that road led Paul to see the
light maybe it would fix Donald Trump as
well the idea being that Trump is
clueless that's the gist of it remember
that a few months ago Donald Trump left
the NATO summit early after world
leaders including the Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau French president
Emmanuel macron and British prime
minister Boris Johnson were caught on
video laughing at Trump here's that
video as a reminder
[Music]
[Music]
Trump so triggered by that one that he
left the NATO summit early and then of
course there was the time that the
entire roomful of the United Nations
national assembly laughed at Donald
Trump's ridiculous hyperbole in 2018 a
particularly orange-looking Trump
getting a laugh but he wasn't telling
any jokes today I stand before the
United Nations General Assembly to share
the extraordinary progress we've made in
less than two years my administration
has accomplished more than almost any
administration in the history of our
country America's so true
didn't expect that reaction but that's
okay
weren't we supposed to be getting away
from the laughingstock president by
electing Donald Trump it's the opposite
it's the same projection it's all the
stuff Trump said Obama was doing or
represented or was Trump actually is all
the things that Trump said Hillary would
do if she were to become president Trump
is actually doing while trying to take
credit for things that he actually had
nothing to do with I'm sick of having a
laughingstock president I want to fix
this let's fix it in November some of
the most difficult to repair damages of
the Donald Trump era are going to be the
Alliance's that have been ruined by
Donald Trump's presence in the Oval
Office and indeed the United Kingdom is
now abandoning its alliance with Donald
Trump over the Iran crisis and we've
talked before about how the United
States is increasingly out of important
climate change discussions worldwide why
would you invite the country that backed
out of the Paris climate Accords and
whose President believes climate change
is a hoax created by the Chinese you
wouldn't
the United staes is increasingly out of
those discussions the u.s. is
increasingly acting alone and
belligerently in international
agreements like the Iran nuclear deal
where Donald Trump decided we're just
simply going to bail we're gonna leave
everybody else in the deal out to dry
despite the reality that Iran did not
violate any element of that deal the
United States is increasingly running
afoul of our allies with actions like
Donald Trump's on Iran in the
unauthorized assassination of Kasim
soleimani which we've been covering and
now we've heard from the UK defence
secretary ben wallace who says that
donald trump's isolationist and
unilateral behavior is making the UK
look for alternative allies this is one
of our most important alliances and
they're saying we're looking elsewhere
here's Ben Wallace speaking to The
Sunday Times two days ago I wonder if
the United States withdraws from its
leadership around the world over the
last year we've had the u.s. pull out
from Syria the statement by Donald Trump
on Iraq where he said NATO should take
cover and do more in the Middle East the
assumptions of 2010 that we were always
going to be part
the u.s. coalition is really just not
where we are going to be regardless of
what the US does we are going to have to
make decisions that allow us to stand
with a range of allies the five eyes
that's the intelligence partnership with
the US Canada Australia and New Zealand
and our European allies where our
interests converge the United Kingdom is
publicly saying this isn't just
happening behind closed doors they are
publicly saying we're not sure but our
alliance with the United States we are
looking elsewhere they're also looking
at reducing their dependence on US
military assets wallace saying we're
very dependent on American air cover and
American intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance assets we need to
diversify our assets which we could see
is good it's good that they'd be
independently sort of sustainable when
it comes to defense but it is also a big
red flag when it comes to foreign policy
and what we've seen as alliances over
the last many decades and meanwhile
Donald Trump is also threatening to
reduce intelligence sharing with the UK
so if you are a total like isolationist
nationalist type you want to build walls
instead of bridges and do everything
ourselves with nobody else you may
actually like this the problem is that
it's absolutely terrible for the United
States economically as well even if you
like isolationism politically and
theoretically in practice in 2020 when
our economy is so interlinked with those
of our allies in so many ways this is
very bad and the scariest thing about it
is that many trumpets aren't worried
they're not scared they're not concerned
about this because Donald Trump has
successfully primed them to see
everything he does as alpha behavior if
allies are abandoning us it's because
Trump has shown them I don't know that
he's doing what's best for the u.s. not
for them and they're realizing now that
Trump exists to make America great again
not to make the UK great so good for
Trump allies abandoning us as a sign
that Donald Trump is doing really well
and this is the type of post facto
reasoning that if Trump
it must have been good for the United
States and that makes the echo chamber
very difficult to pierce so this story
is about the Alliance's that will take a
long time to repair once Donald Trump is
gone but it's also a story about the way
in which a trumpet is able to justify
any action that Donald Trump takes see
if it's a or if it's the opposite of a
either way it's Trump doing the right
thing if Trump did something that
impressed the UK and made them say wow
Trump did something good you have Trump
is saying look at what a great job
Donald Trump is doing or just like he
said he's making the u.s. respected or
whatever which Donald Trump said we
weren't under Barack Obama but we would
be again under Donald Trump if our
allies abandon us the same trumpet will
insist
Trump's doing what he promised it's
America first here it's make America
great again screw our allies Donald
Trump is here to do what's best for the
United States and then on the tail end
of this you have the geopolitical
considerations who will come in who will
take leadership responsibilities we've
seen it sort of to a degree be German
Chancellor Angela Merkel but this is a
perfect example of why Vladimir Putin
loves the instability caused by Donald
Trump a West that is increasingly
leaderless looking for a leader
realigning those alliances that's an
opportunity for Russia period and this
is you don't even have to get into Putin
help Trump beat Hillary it's not an
analysis of interference or any of that
it's simply an analysis of the real
world
Vladimir Putin benefits and sees
opportunity as a result of weakened
leadership in North America and Western
Europe and Donald Trump is perpetuating
that in this vicious cycle that is
endlessly defended by his followers in a
style reminiscent of a combination of
George Orwell's 1984 but of course also
brave new world by Aldous Huxley so we
talked about the impeachment use the
house sending impeachment articles to
the Senate they've approved seven
impeachment managers who will be
effectively serving as prosecutors
during the impeachment trial I believe
with a 99% degree of confit
that an acquittal for Donald Trump is
what is awaiting us at the end of this
trial this has made Donald Trump
short-circuit he immediately blew a
gasket and started tweeting nonsense
yesterday let's look at what happened as
he learned that Democrats were indeed
moving forward and sending articles of
impeachment to the Senate which remember
he claimed to want initially when he was
impeached in the house and Nancy Pelosi
said I'm going to hold the articles
until such time that I believe I can get
a fair trial Donald Trump said she can't
do that she's got to move forward it's
got to go now that it's happening Trump
again blows a gasket and there's a lot
here because Donald Trump seemed
genuinely thrown by this Donald Trump
tweeting crying chuck schumer just said
the american people want a fair trial in
the senate true but why didn't novice
Nancy and corrupt politician Adam Schiff
T Schiff
give us a fair trial in the house it was
the most lopsided and unfair basement
hearing in the history of Congress there
are so many lies and deceptions there
that it would take a long time to go
through them all the basement hearing
thing remember Republicans could be part
of those of questioning those witnesses
and reviewing those documents that's a
lie
the nicknaming nervous Nancy corrupt
politician Adam Schiff tisha
I find it very funny I find it effective
I obviously don't believe the smears
that are implied there and then again
the idea that there was no fair trial in
the house it's not a trial in the house
it's a hearing Donald Trump was invited
and he refused to go on the basis that
it would not have been fair but then he
says the fact that he didn't participate
as evidence of unfairness well if you go
and it would be unfair and if you don't
go and it's unfair that's not really an
honest assessment of what went on Donald
Trump continuing on Twitter going on to
say here we go again another con job by
the do-nothing Democrats again
do-nothing they impeached you so they're
doing something all of this work was
supposed to be done by the house not the
Senate Trump seemingly misunderstanding
how the constitutionally enshrined
process of impeachment works then in
comes Donald Trump jr.
not the dumbest of the Trump adult
children but certainly not the one with
the most common sense either starting to
tweet stuff like for example Rand is
100% right if we hear from witnesses we
should hear from them all hunter Joe BS
whistleblower Schiff etc if Republicans
continue the DEM one way sham because
they're too weak to fight like Pelosi
they don't deserve to be reelected and
then of course what you have to
understand is that they want to make
impeachment about Adam Schiff or the
Biden's they want to out the
whistleblower this is not actually about
Joe and hunter Biden we knew they would
try to make it about Joe and hunter
Biden but what Donald Trump did is what
Donald Trump did and the the the crony
istic nature of hunter Biden being on
the board of this gas company we can all
agree it's problematic as a systemic
issue but it does not go to the
specifics of what Donald Trump did so
distraction distortion all of it then
Don jr. retweeting some guy named Paul
Sperry who said quote Nadler Jessica
Nadler just complained the Senate is
engaging in a disgusting cover-up by not
putting on Democrats witnesses but the
only cover up is impeachment itself
Schiff Pelosi Biden and he cites a name
that is sometimes attributed to be one
of the whistleblowers all trying to
cover up their own roles in Ukrainian
corruption ayoh election interference
then retweeting Republican congressman
Lee Zeldin who says the most relevant to
witnesses on the obstruction of Congress
charge are Jerry Nadler and Adam Schiff
so during this impeachment trial there
is going to be a persistent non-stop
campaign of disinformation and
distraction and character assassination
and we just have to be ready for it we
are looking at how much of the
impeachment trial will be public how
much of it can we reasonably stream on
YouTube and twitch with commentary with
the staffing resources that we have our
resources were stretched basically to
the max
during the impeachment hearings in the
house Intel and Judiciary Committee's
sometimes 12-hour streams in a single
day this is really important so we're
doing what we can to plan around how to
bring as much of this to you on our
platforms as possible we want to be
covering all of it that's the plan I'll
hopefully have more information for you
about that on Monday the way this is
expected to go is at first there will be
like three to four full days of what the
Senate would call housekeeping before
the trial even starts setting rules and
establishing procedures they would then
send a summons to trump for a plea
I'm sure Trump will plead not guilty
they will then figure out which
witnesses are we going to call are we
sending subpoenas scheduling witnesses
this could be weeks in total the Senate
has to vote on each subpoena it's going
to be wild Mitch McConnell has said that
the Senate will be in session six days a
week to keep things moving Bill
Clinton's impeachment trial lasted five
weeks this one could be the same it is
going to start to overlap and conflict
with the twenty20 primaries it is going
to be an historic event and we are going
to be here for it to the extent that we
can probably more news on Monday about
the particulars in the meantime again if
you see a conviction at the end of this
let me know on Twitter at D Pakman or in
a comment down below by leaving a
comment I do want to hear from you
alright so the corporate media smear
campaign against Bernie Sanders has
begun and it's not only disgusting but
it's pretty transparent as well just
yesterday we were talking about Bernie
has taken the lead in a key
gold-standard Iowa poll the Des Moines
Register poll and here's how CNN spun it
and here's how MSNBC spun it and the
smears are now starting to ramp up and
the big breaking story from yesterday
the first weekday after Bernie did
really well in that Des Moines Register
poll is that allegedly Bernie told
Elizabeth Warren in private nearly two
years ago that a woman can't win the
2020 President presidential election and
Elizabeth Warren has now sort of
confirmed it and lo and behold what a
coincidence the story about this
conversation was broken by CNN yesterday
and CNN just happens to be hosting
tonight's Democratic presidential debate
this is one of those really important
stories to dissect because there are
actually two actually that there are
really three stories here and I'm not
seeing anybody talk about all of them so
let's do that
Story number one is what we knew would
happen I mean is Bernie's viability as a
possible Democratic nominee became more
clear corporate media which is in league
with the establishment would do more and
more to smear Bernie Sanders it's
happening it happened within hours of me
going live with that story yesterday I
don't actually think we need to spend
that much time on that story today
because we just did a bunch about it
yesterday I think most of you understand
it we just happened to report that it
would be happening rather than reporting
about it after the fact I think we're
all on the same page as far as that
story goes story number two is whether
the assertion is true so let's discuss
that now what are the facts that are
being alleged here the claim is that
back in December of 2018
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders who
are friends met at Elizabeth Warren's
apartment in Washington DC they knew
they'd likely be running against each
other to the end of the Democratic
presidential campaign they reportedly
agreed let's be civil with each other
let's not attack each other let's avoid
hurting the progressive movement great
seems that that part is the agreed-upon
context of this meeting as the story was
told to CNN by four sources that they
cite who I'll talk about soon Elizabeth
Warren reportedly said to Bernie I think
I can make a robust argument about the
economy I think if I run I can earn
broad support from Women Voters and
Bernie Sanders responded that he does
not believe a woman can win presumably
he meant in 2020 running against
incumbent Donald Trump so who are the
sources CNN cites for people to people
Elizabeth Warren spoke with directly
after the encounter two people that are
familiar with the meeting
that's what CNN says three of those four
sources said that Elizabeth Warren told
Bernie Sanders she disagrees with his
assessment that a woman could not win so
we were very quickly dealing with is the
report accurate Bernie Sanders denied
that the characterization of his
statement is accurate I think that's
important and I'll explain why when we
get to part three of this story and then
Elizabeth Warren put out a statement
yesterday saying that indeed this is
something Bernie Sanders said Elizabeth
Warren saying Bernie and I met for more
than two hours in December of 2018 to
discuss the 2020 election our past work
together and our shared goals beating
Donald Trump taking back our government
from the wealthy and well-connected and
building an economy that works for
everyone
among the topics that came up was what
would happen if Democrats nominated a
female candidate I thought a woman could
win he disagreed I have no interest in
discussing this private meeting any
further because Bernie and I have far
more in common than our differences on
punditry I'm in this race to talk about
how about what's broken in the country
and how to fix it that's what I'm going
to continue to do I know Bernie's in the
race for the same reason we have been
friends and allies in this fight for a
long time and I have no doubt we will
continue to work together to defeat
Donald Trump and put our government on
the side of the people so again she says
we disagreed about whether a woman could
win which gets us to layer number three
which is the context here the story is
being framed as Bernie simply saying
women cannot be President do any of you
believe Bernie Sanders would say
something equivalent to a woman cannot
be President of the United States here
is Bernie a long time ago saying a woman
can be President of the United States
the real issue is not whether you're
black or white whether you're a woman or
a man in my view a woman could be
elected president of the United States
the real issue is whose side are you on
are you on the side of workers and poor
people or are you on the side of big
money and the corporation so aside from
whether the assertions about what was
said are true the real tragedy here is
that this is
being portrayed as evidence of Bernie's
sexism or misogyny or whatever and it
simply is not that and if there's a
criticism of Elizabeth Warren here and
there is it's that she in her statement
alludes to the context but doesn't
straight-up say the context is not a
sexist context it's a disagreement over
whether in the political environment in
2020 against Donald Trump
a female Democratic candidate could be
President now Bernie could be wrong
about that Bernie Sanders might be of
the opinion that because of sexism in
the United States or because of how
Donald Trump has clouded norms when it
comes to how you're supposed to treat
women that Bernie believes in 2020
sexism would cause a woman to lose to
Donald Trump now you can say it's such a
broad statement it doesn't make sense
that any woman would lose if it's the
right woman women are so different it
makes no sense to say no woman could win
so you can say I disagree with what
Bernie said and it sounds like that's
what Elizabeth Warren said to him but to
say Bernie is sexist even if he said it
absent any context is ridiculous let me
give an example imagine that I said I
don't think a Jewish person can be
president in 2020 talking about Bernie
Sanders for example Bernie Sanders is a
Jewish man is that anti-semitic of
course not
if I believe that because of anti-jewish
bias and anti-semitism and the rise of
white nationalism that a Jewish
candidate would be unable to win in 2020
that's not anti-semitic now if I say
Jews shouldn't be President or no Jew
could ever be President or Jews simply
should never run because of whatever
then we have something to talk about so
if Bernie's analysis of the country at
the time as a woman couldn't win in 2020
that's not sexist now I happen to
disagree with Bernie I think many people
could defeat Donald Trump if they're the
right people they could be men they
could be women the implicit smear of
Bernie if he said this is where this
goes on the rail so at some point
Elizabeth Warren if she does believe
because remember in her statement she
says Bernie Ann
I basically stand for the same things we
agree about what needs to happen in this
country he thinks a woman can't win I
think a woman can win
she should actually clarify and say the
discussion was not a discussion that is
an adjudication of a woman in the role
of the presidency
it was a strategic opinion about given
the circumstances in the country whether
a woman could or couldn't win Elizabeth
Warren to do the right thing and clarify
that if that's what she believes because
she's playing coy she's confirming the
story that is being used to smear Bernie
alluding to context that is not a sexist
contest context but not saying it so if
you're asking me should Elizabeth Warren
clarify that she absolutely should when
you see endless conservatives say a
woman shouldn't be president right it's
not an insane thing to question could a
woman win in 2020 the counterpoint of
course is Hillary got millions more
votes than Trump in 2016 and were it not
for 77 thousand votes in three states
she would have won so I just disagree
with Bernie's analysis but that's all it
is
if Bernie said I don't think women
should run for president we are talking
about something very very different so
let's step back now okay consider what's
going on here weeks before the Iowa
caucus right after Bernie takes the lead
in Iowa takes a lead in California
polling out of the blue CNN just happens
to report an Elizabeth Warren just so
happens to recall this two-year old
conversation being couched as Bernie
being sexist which is completely
antithetical to everything Bernie
Sanders has fought for for the last 40
years so here's how it's going down
CNN published the story yesterday and
they they just so happen to be hosting
tonight's Democratic presidential debate
what a coincidence
every minute during tonight's debate
that is about this Bernie Warren thing
helps Joe Biden the prediction is when
this issue invariably comes up tonight
Elizabeth Warren will refer to Bernie as
her friend and say that they have a
similar vision for what needs to happen
in the US Bernie Sanders will
of course a woman can be President but
moderators will keep going until they
can generate something more salacious
after the debate the spin will be Bernie
and Warren getting very chippy there
while elder statesmen Biden was
presidential he was focused on policy
and of course Biden will be able to
focus on policy tonight because CNN
won't bog him down with questions based
on this article they wrote about Bernie
and Warren which will be used to justify
questions during the debate tonight so
Bernie has been set up for an unwinnable
situation in tonight's debate if he
tries to focus on the issues he'll be
accused of dodging the questions about
Elizabeth Warren and sexism if he
buckles down and refutes the attack and
says Elizabeth Warren should clarify the
context was a strategic one not a sexist
one he will be accused of being too mean
in defending himself and if he doesn't
strongly defend himself he'll be
criticized for not strongly defending
himself against the allegations I said a
couple of weeks ago this election is
going to be extra ugly and I was mostly
talking about the general it's quickly
getting that way in the primary this is
on day one where I said I'm not going to
participate in these smears that can
only serve to divide the progressive
movement and prop up an establishment
candidate like Joe Biden this is what we
were talking about this is exactly what
we were talking about so Elizabeth
Warren if she believes the context was
not a sexist one she believes what
Bernie says has been saying for a long
time that a woman certainly can be
President and that this was a strategic
discussion she should clarify it because
otherwise she is actually participating
in dividing the movement and we should
very clearly state that absent context
this really doesn't tell us very much
one way or the other and in the end this
helps Joe Biden because remember if this
hurts Bernie imagine that this goes
shockingly well and it pulls three
points of support from Bernie Sanders
and imagine that Elizabeth Warren gets
all
three of those points even though the
polling tells us she would really only
get 1/3 of any support that is pulled
away from Bernie but imagine that this
cost Bernie three points and Warren
gains three points Biden still winning
it still doesn't help Elizabeth Warren
take the lead and that's why this props
up the establishment right now the
leading establishment candidate is Joe
Biden tell me where you disagree I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman follow me the show
is on twitter at david pakman show one
of the busiest 24 hours of news in a
long time so let's get right into it we
had Democratic presidential debate
number seven last night and it was the
most shameful one so far in terms of the
hosting and the anchoring done yesterday
by CNN of course as you probably now
know CNN on Monday published this
exclusive report about how Bernie
Sanders in 2018 supposedly told
Elizabeth Warren that a woman can't win
the presidency and then there was the
pretext of that used to create drama
during the debate exactly as I predicted
would be done and in general we'll get
to that but in general
CNN filled the debate with baiting
questions and split screens trying to
get people to fight basically nobody
took the bait and that was actually a
good decision by the candidates they
wasted time with these open-ended
questions like what makes you qualified
to be president which at this late stage
of the game just weeks before the first
votes are lame worthless Wes waste of
time questions CNN wrote follow-up
questions in advance which makes sense
to have but the questions ignored the
candidates actual answers so the debate
was filled with follow-up questions from
CNN that were complete non sequiturs
completely ignoring what the candidates
were actually saying really embarrassing
and the biggest example of this was when
they asked Bernie about when he
supposedly told Elizabeth Warren a woman
couldn't win Bernie denied it and they
go right to Elizabeth Warren saying how
did you feel when Bernie said
woman couldn't win Bernie just denied it
and they skip over asking Elizabeth
Warren well Bernie denies it can you
clarify are you sure he said it was
there context nothing
look at this embarrassing moment from
yesterday's debate CNN reported
yesterday that and senator Sanders
senator Warren confirmed in a statement
that in 2018 you told her that you did
not believe that a woman could win the
election why did you say that well as a
matter of fact I didn't say oh and I
don't want to waste a whole lot of time
on this because this is what Donald
Trump and maybe some of the media want
anybody knows me knows that it's
incomprehensible that I would think that
a woman could not be President of the
United States go to you two today there
are some video of it of me 30 years ago
talking about how a woman could become
president of the United States in 2015 I
deferred in fact the Senate Awards was a
movement to draft Senator Warren to run
for president and you know what I said
stay back senator Warren decided not to
run an I date I did run afterwards
Hillary Clinton won the popular vote by
three million votes how could anybody in
a million years not believe that a woman
could become president of the United
States and let me be very clear if any
of the women on this stage or any of the
men on this stage win the nomination I
hope that's not the case I don't me but
if they do I will do everything in my
power to make sure that they are elected
in order to defeat the most dangerous
president in the history of our country
so senator Sanders senator Sanders I do
want to be clear
you're saying that you never told
senator Warren that a woman could not
win the election that is correct
senator Warren what did you think when
senators Andrew Sanders told you a woman
could not win the election I disagreed
Bernie says I didn't say it next
question is hey Elizabeth what did you
think of what did you think of Bernie
saying that this is not how you run a
debate and then afterwards they premise
a full question round on it going to
other people with the title on screen
saying what do you say to people who
think a woman can't win the election
it's like who nobody has admitted to
saying that Bernie just denied having
said that it was almost a Saturday Night
Live parody of what a debate would look
like but unfortunately it was the actual
debate now by the way not to Pat myself
on the back but word for word
I called how this would go down two days
ago I tweeted on Monday prediction when
it comes up tomorrow Warren will refer
to Bernie as her friend and Bernie will
say of course a woman can be President
but the moderators will keep going check
out what Elizabeth Warren said I
disagreed Bernie is my friend and I am
NOT here to try to fight with Bernie and
then Bernie Sanders later getting the
opportunity to clarify and literally use
the words I tweeted on Monday of course
a woman can be President this is no big
pat on my back it's that obvious how it
would go and with what CNN would try to
do with it we could anticipate how
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders
would handle it now on policy there were
some interesting moments the candidates
were asked would you bring all troops
home from the Middle East
no one said yes and this tricked some
people Elizabeth Warren said she would
bring all combat troops home that's
playing coy with combat versus
peacekeeping okay and you have to
understand that when I tweeted about
this last night a few people wrote back
and said no Warren said she would bring
everybody home no she said she would get
combat troops out of the region that is
a way of not really answering the
question Bernie Sanders for example a
lot of people thought no
he said he would bring them all home
Bernie Sanders listed things that we
would be better off having troops do
than be in the Middle East but Bernie
also didn't say that they would all come
come home and this is actually not
shocking it would be unrealistic for a
presidential candidate who understands
anything about geopolitics to say every
troop is coming home from the Middle
East because the reality is some troops
are going to stay in some places in the
Middle East whether Bernie's president
whether Warren's president whether
Biden's president or whether Trump is
reelected president that's just being
realistic but if you listen to how they
said it none of them said they're all
coming home there was a discussion about
health care costs Bernie was asked about
the price of his plan and he was asked
multiple times don't we deserve to hear
the price tag
Bernie has given us the price tag and
now you can argue Bernie's price tag is
wrong if you want to that's a legitimate
conversation to have but to continue to
pretend that Bernie has never addressed
the cost of his plan again more of this
staging by CNN which we'll have more
about tomorrow
that was adversarial to Bernie to save a
lease they also focused on the cost of
health care without ever mentioning the
cost of wars or military interventions
which is very typical in these sort of
establishment debates when it comes to
foreign policy Pete Budaj edge didn't
have a particularly good night often his
answers were very consultant like in a
way he would state what the problem is
in society or in the economy and say
that we must fix it and then his time
was up that those aren't solutions it's
not policy to restate what the problem
is it's great that he understands the
problem he sounded good doing it in his
polished way but not a particularly good
night for Pete Budaj
the topic of free college came up again
and once again Budaj edge repeating this
thing about I don't want the children of
rich people to go to school for free
this is the wrong position if you have a
system where everybody pays in on the
basis of their income in order to fund a
tuition free state schools if the rich
are paying in
their kids should be able to get it
otherwise the rich will start arguing we
shouldn't have to pay into something
that we can't benefit from remember most
of them are going to go to private
schools anyway mayor Pete is just wrong
on this let them get their free tuition
to a state school if they want to go
because they paid in it's a policy
disagreement and I think he's flat wrong
on it
lastly Tom Steyer actually didn't do bad
billionaire Tom Steyer bought his way
into the debates I don't support him I
don't think we need another billionaire
president I don't plan to vote for Tom
Styer but yesterday he actually did ok
he brought up climate change a couple of
times when it went well
here's one clip of Tom Styer this white
climate is my number one priority and
I'm still shocked that I'm the only
person on this stage who will say this I
would declare a state of emergency on
day one on climate I would I would do it
from the standpoint of environmental
justice and make sure we go to the black
and brown communities where you can't
breathe the air or drink the water that
comes out of the tap safely but I also
know this we're gonna create millions of
good-paying Union jobs across this
country it's gonna be the biggest job
program in American history so I know we
have to do it I know we can do it and I
know that we can do it in a way that
makes us healthier that makes us better
paid and is more just steyr did better
than Pete Budaj edge he did better than
Amy Klobuchar and in fact he did better
than Joe Biden as well who was
extraordinarily low-energy yesterday and
Biden probably benefited from not
getting as much speaking time if I
recall as Elizabeth Warren and as Bernie
Sanders so who won the debate if you
evaluate yesterday's debate from the
perspective of the average person I
believe this was a de facto win for
Biden this doesn't mean Biden did
anything great
remember the more Biden talks the worse
it is for him but CNN did what we knew
they would do they successfully pulled
Warren and Bernie into the story about
whether or not Bernie said a woman can't
win they did an entire round of
questions about it on policy Warren did
fine Bernie did fine there was nothing
new or surprising about the policies
they were advocating for they've been
doing it for six prior debates to
yesterday seventh debate but low enter
she Biden was able as I predicted to
just talk about policy and even though
he kind of bumbled through it it frames
him as presidential and the net effect
yesterday with Amy Klobuchar being a
non-factor
Tom Styer basically a non-factor Budaj
edge certainly didn't do anything to
claw his way back into this thing the de
facto result is Biden gets another
couple weeks now where he remains the
front-runner with no major obvious
blunder despite just not sounding good
at all
that is going to pull him out of first
place I know that to you and I we watch
this stuff closely Biden seemed slow
confused at times centrist policies that
don't appeal to me but if you think
about this through the average voters
eyes the muddled Bernie versus Warren
thing is not going to take Biden out of
first place in fact it's gonna
perpetuate it and that was exactly the
goal of the Bernie smear that started on
Monday so overall a completely botched
debate following the predictable CNN
playbook to a tee tell me where I'm
wrong check out some of the things I was
tweeting as the debate was going on last
night at D Pakman and tell me where you
disagree